thank you very much for being with us um
so what do you make of Sam Juma entering
the race well it's obviously creating
quite a crowded field he certainly took
us by surprise this morning but you know
it's part of what needs to be a big
conversation I get in the guess and the
Conservative Party about the type of
leadership that they wanted the reason
that I'm standing is because I think we
need a different type of leadership at
this time
that's about more than shouting at the
other side and bossing everybody about
we have to carefully put together the
governing party into a majority that
will deliver a brexit deal which is what
I did back in January when the what
became known as the multi house
compromise emerged and produced the
majority in the House of Commons and so
looking for a different way of leading
the party that as I say carefully puts
together the different wings of the
party in an agreement that can then be
presented to the EU as a way for what I
think is critical for us now is that is
there any evidence though there anyone
else agrees with you that the ones have
a different style of leadership in the
Conservative Party with respect no one
is talking about you as the next prime
minister well I've got a number of
supporters who have declared already and
hopefully over the next few weeks I will
persuade people that's the case I mean
one of the things we have to get away
from I think is a kind of bifurcated
debate where you know that the
competition itself becomes a problem
after the event so that to put the thing
back together again and one of the
problems that we've had during the whole
brexit debate has been this sort of
binary move into silos if we're going to
find some kind of resolution before the
31st of October we have to bring
everybody out of those silos put them in
a room together find some way to
navigate towards an agreement that
everybody can focus on to get us over
the line for brexit now as I say we
managed to do that back in January
people as far apart as Nicky Morgan and
Jacob Riis morg and Steve Baker came
into a room together we sat down
together over a big bowl of chocolate to
get a deal hammered out and I think it's
as I say it takes a different kind of
leadership to make that happen the
greatest achievement of that of the
Malthouse compromise again with respect
it's perhaps more than the compromise
element rather than the Malthouse part
of it as you say political opponents did
put aside
their differences it's just unfortunate
that they did so for a plan described by
the European Union variously as bonkers
and just nonsense yeah so when the
compromise came out it was at a
particular time I think where the EU was
very fixated on getting that withdrawal
agreement through as was the government
and so the contemplation of anything
different was naturally going to be
dismissed right because they wanted what
they wanted now the dynamic has changed
since and what we know now is that the
withdrawal agreement is currently
drafted will not pass the House of
Commons right there we know that the
backstop within it makes that assert it
will not go through and so we have a
duty to find a different kind of
agreement and what I would do as Prime
Minister you know within a shorter space
as possible is present a new type of
agreement and a new agreement that we
know would pass the House of Commons and
say to the EU this is the deal that we
want we're not choosing no deal but this
is the deal that we want and we know we
can get a majority and frankly you have
a duty as we have a duty to respect your
structures and democracy you have a duty
to respect ours and that means that
coming together as a group of great
democracies we have to find a way
through critical to that will be of
course dealing with the situation in
Ireland I was in Northern Ireland on
Friday
talking to groups they're constructively
about how we might try and find a way
through for their legitimate concerns
the complexities of that particular
situation and so a constructive
leadership that puts together a
governing majority I think will be
critical at this time but just to
examine your strategizing when the last
plan that you came up with involved
technology that doesn't exist yet and
I'm still waiting for a hoverboard
yeah that's not correct the range you're
talking about the European Union about
coming up with something fresh to do so
you need to compromise you will need to
give ground to the European Union where
does that going to happen
so first of all that's a common
misconception this technological thing I
mean I know it was it took off in the
press but in truth what the groups
around alternative arrangements have
pointed out repeatedly is that relies on
existing systems and technology checks
away from the border trusted trader
there's lots of complexity in there but
nevertheless existing stuff and there's
no there's not really in the world where
there aren't actually checks on the
border that's critically of course in
the second set of negotiations that took
place both the EU and the UK government
committed to
this idea of alternative arrangements
and there is significant work going on
in fact mr. Katainen who's the vice
president of the Commission gave a press
conference back in April where he said
they are specifically working on a new
system for checks at the border in
northern Iran to avoid a visible border
so there is work going on and there is a
just a question of when that happens not
so if yes so whereas they go where's the
compromise
well the compromise is that we as I say
we will put forward a an agreement that
we know will garner support in the House
of Commons
now the will there's possible to be some
negotiation around that within that we
want to have will obviously have to have
some kind of option of a transition
agreement but where we want to find
agreement with the EU is because both
sides want to try and avoid no deal and
we have to reverse the dynamic of the
negotiation so we put it back on to the
EU that if they won't take a deal which
is eminently reasonable which has
consent through democratic processes in
the UK then they are effectively
pointing away to No Deal for ours and
for them and that's something that's
profoundly to be avoided so you think
that the suggestion from Michel gulfs
camp this morning that there could be a
delay to brexit of as much as a year
perhaps even longer than that to get a
deal done you think that's a good idea
no I don't I've haven't voted to support
any kind of extension to the process now
I think you could see a short technical
extension if you needed it if a
principal had been agreed you know worth
the wait for an agreement that was in
place but I think we have to be honest
with ourselves that wherever we if we
get to the 31st of October
without an agreement in place then there
are no good choices available to a prime
minister at that point you know and we
will be on a hair-trigger for a general
election which could be devastating for
the country and catapult it into a sort
of chaotic mix of who knows what so we
need to get a deal through and the only
way I think we can do that is by
presenting something which fundamentally
has the consent of the British
Parliament first and that means as I say
a new kind of leadership that puts that
deal together
I mean you are Housing Minister I mean
there is something of a crisis in
housing and the moment steps have been
taken me don't you have better things to
do well I certainly am spending a lot of
my time on the housing that sure for
sure and we've did 222 thousand new
houses last year the numbers for next
year were looking good and housing forms
a critical part of my kind of
three-strand program once we're through
brexit of job house school a new social
contract the
these are the building blocks of a
brilliant life you know that we want
fantastic well-funded schools
secure homes for everybody and a stable
job that people can rely on that you
give those three things to most people
and they will fly right so it's it's
central and experience that I've had in
housing over the last few months as
Housing Minister is is critical to
making sure that we hit that big number
of 300,000 homes by the mid-2020s